To help detox catalytium, he suggests two times a week EDTA IV twice per week with a few weeks following MRI. Your thoughts on this?
Well, EDTA is really your strongest key later in my book. So keylators are in my book are the students mild, moderate and strong keylators.
Remember, chelation is the part of detoxification that I call phase zero detoxification. You have to make sure that phase one, two, three, four, five, six are working really healthfully.
And most of our patients are already working on all those things. That's part of what you're doing.
So you probably could do EDTA chelation. A couple of caveats to that. Do you have any mercury fillings? Well, the answer to that is yes, then you absolutely better not be doing EDTA IV chelation. That's just crossed off the list.
No.
And so there is some negatives to it. I am not a great big fan of IV chelation because ETA such a strong key later, it's been called to actually key like a plastic out of the bag that it's founded in the chelation bag and can cause plastic issues.
A big fan of EDTA chelation, but that's just my opinion. I heard personally, if I had acute arstic toxicity, absolutely take IV, EDTA chelation, but you know, that's just going to be a personal choice.
I'm not completely against it. If you have any metals in your body, if you have the nickel plate of your job, you have mercury fillings in your teeth, you do not ever do any EDTA IV chelation.
I think of zeolite to help detox, again, let him absolutely, zeolite is a moderate key later, you can do that either with mercury fillings, zeolite is a great key later and a binder could actually ask actually binder to so it's great.
I've offered a vitamin C powder for per cancellations, which is calcium escorbate. Is that a bad idea? No, I don't know what the milligrams of that is, I have to look that up.
There's a magnesium escorbate and a potassium escorbate too. I think that's just that buffering agents. So it's not like you're taking it for the calcium or for the magnesium that's buffering it in your stomach. So the idea of a buffer vitamin C is it's vitamin C can be irritating to your stomach.
It's acidic. It's a scorbic acid and it can just be irritating to a person's stomach. So you buffering it with some minerals helps call that helps you absorb it better.
In this case, you're not taking it and these minerals are to the high dose where you're getting a poor source of minerals. So I think that's just fine.
I also take pure encapsulations, magnesium, citrate, malactyl. I think pure encapsulations uses albion attract minerals in their minerals. So I think you're fine with that.
How many clear multiband plus do I take if I were you, because you asked the question about I would take for a day of those.
How do we get a new insert for our right cases.
I have traveled with it so much the bottom piece is getting kind of ready and tortoise. I need to replace it the next few months. I can do I contact true right. Yes, I would contact true right for this.
And by the way, true right is updating their websites. If you go to look up search true right there. Their website is actually down completely because they're doing a whole re update on their website.
It might take a couple days for them to get done. We contacted them today. So they said it might not be until tomorrow night or Friday before the website is up. So don't think that they folded your stuff like that.
I got an email from true right. But I think it said that there was a flu update. Maybe. So there may be a 2022 update. But again, they're correct. We're discussing on the frequencies that are going to be valuable, but doesn't mean that those are going to be the specific frequencies of the virus that you're exposed to.
However, I said there's like a thousand at the end of the year that are right around in society.
Is it better to run black seed oil on my skin near my pancreas or to ingest it?
Well, you're not going to absorb a lot of black seed oil through your skin. So definitely ingest it would be a better way to get that for sure.